Aaron is with us in San Antonio
hi Karen welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave hey what's up hey I'm on baby
step 7 and my financial advisor says
that I can retire anytime I'm 59 but I'm
a little leery about doing that I'm
wondering what kind of factors I need to
look at to make my decision to retire or
not is your investments making enough
income for you to live off of like you
want to live there they're ok they're
not making a tremendous amount but I
mean I'm I've got about 650 in
investments the ranch is probably worth
about 400 the ranch making you money uh
barely breaks even
ok that's not that's not creating my
live on there so 650 is creating how
much money sixty thousand a year maybe
um yeah sixty thousand yeah I'd say
about that yeah and where my husband and
I are both retired Air Force so we get
our pensions which is how much mine's
about 65 a year his is about going to be
about 20,000 a year okay so I get
$150,000 household income yeah well
right now I'm working as a nursing
assistant and if you quit oh yeah I'm
thinking yeah I got 60 I got 65 and 60
and 28 is what I got
yes yes counting the business you're
right okay and the business yeah the
business if I retire I would sell it cuz
it's a horse business and it's expensive
that's the ranch yeah that's the ranch
its break-even I was talking about your
income oh well I I do it anesthesia so
it's about two hundred thousand a year
now you miss out you're misunderstanding
me I'm sorry when you when you retire
you would have the Air Force income and
you would have sixty thousand off of
your investments that's a hundred and
twenty five thousand plus you said your
husband has 28 thousand coming in from
pension right yes sir okay that puts you
two hundred and fifty thousand those
pieces do not counting the horses which
break even and not counting your nursin
Estes is right right and so can you make
it on 150 yes I could okay then then you
can make it because you're making it off
the airforce retirement and off of the
650 you have invested now if you sell
the business that gives you money I
guess yes yes I can probably sell it for
about a hundred thousand I would put
another hundred in the investments which
would make another ten or so give or
take
okay well and so I mean I'm just using
round numbers they might make eight in
my leg seven but whatever it might make
twelve so anywhere in there something
like that so rough numbers yeah you can
the thing is you're fifty nine you make
$200,000 a year so you're an economic
engine you make a ton of money I mean do
you want to just completely quit or you
want to slow down or do you want to
change the terms of your deal or what um
I guess I I honestly I would like to
just quit and retire and enjoy my family
mm-hmm okay all right
well 59 is early to do that and have
absolutely no nothing going on except
enjoying your family just from
experience mm-hmm but so if I were you I
would keep your certifications and so
forth up okay
in case you decided you wanted to go
back and pick up 20 hours a week or
something just for kicks
okay because you got you have a very
valuable career and if you're going to
step away from it do so in such a way
that you can step back if you chose to
right like maybe do a trial period of
retirement if I like it or not yeah
because the good news is you know you're
in such demand you can you can kind of
set your own terms
yes in terms of when and how you work
and so forth and and so I just don't
want you to not be able to do that five
years from now if you wake up bored out
of your gourd okay I think I understood
that's what I'm saying
and so yeah I think you're in financial
advisors giving you accurate information
what you've given me if you make it all
I'm doing is can you live on what you
have in that scenario and those three
numbers you gave me give me a hundred
and fifty and I think you can probably
do it on that yeah I think so too
I think so too hey good question thank
you for joining us and congratulations
you've done a great job building your
wealth and getting your financial act
together there's a lot of you out there
thank goodness
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind